Digital Theatre is a company that offers educational material...
...for schools, for universities, for libraries.
We're providing a product that helps young people get access to theater...
...that otherwise they just really wouldn't have.
There's a whole broad aspect here of preparing students to go into the real world.
We'll call into Australia.
We will have seminars and webinars with school groups in the US.
We sell into schools all around the world.
What makes Digital Theatre so unique: other people, without question.
Teamwork is not necessarily people working together.
It's working with people you trust.
And that's how it feels like at Digital Theater.